Kento Nanami’s life journey has been one
hell of a rollercoaster ride...
From being an average Jujutsu Student who
watched his best friend pass away, to that
of a depressed salaryman who had no meaning
at all in life, to finally one of the stronger
Sorcerers in Jujutsu Kaisen and someone who
drove me to create this channel.
BUT let’s not forget that Nanami’s also
a complete badass, like the first time he
showed up and went into overtime mode was
as someone who hated working overtime, pure
bliss!
Anyways, Kento Nanami is a grade one jujutsu
sorcerer who after 10 or 11 years as a salaryman
quit his everyday job and returned to the
Jujutsu Academy to work with Gojo.
The reason that he left the academy in the
first place is that Nanami hated the lessons
that were being taught to him when it came
to accepting that they must throw away their
lives.
He felt that everyone held a value in this
world and that their lives were precious.
So naturally with Sorcerers being people who
put their lives on the line day in and day
out for the safety of a civilian population,
who didnt even know what they did, it struck
a cord within our man.
Especially after seeing the death of his closest
friend Yu, id say that was the final straw
that made him step down.
History/Background
So back in the past and as I slightly mentioned
before, Nanami had once been a student at
Tokyo Jujutsu High.
During his first year in 2006, he found himself
working with Yu Haibara.
Together, they joined the second years Suguru
and Gojo to help them on a mission in Okinawa,
more specifically as protection during the
erasure of Riko.
After protecting the airport and I guess doing
some bodyguard work, it basically turned into
more of a summer vacation for them than a
mission.
After a year had passed, Nanami again teams
up with Yu for a more difficult mission where
they were assigned to defeat a cursed spirit
which was believed to be grade 2.
However, after arriving and discovering that
the Cursed Spirit wasnt a pathetic one and
had become more powerful off the emotions
of nearby people.
It was revealed as a grade 1 cursed spirit
that was far too strong for Yu or Nanami to
deal with.
Sadly this ended up resulting in Yu Haibara’s
death!
Nanami took Yu’s death differently from
everyone else as the duo had formed a close
bond over their time together as first years.
Id say that Nanami’s views on being a jujutsu
sorcerer were warped in this moment and like
I previously mentioned it fully drove him
to disown Jujutsu Society.
Anyway, Nanami
still did graduate from Jujutsu High, but
instantly decided to stop being a sorcerer
because he found it as a pain in the butt,
and had already had way too many traumatic
experiences through it.
So that pretty much brings us to today, back
in 2016 or 17 with Nanami re-joining Jujutsu
society after taking away the bread girls
shoulder pain.
Something that I absolutely love and didnt
realize until recently was what Nanami’s
name means.
So, Kento means “Cure for Depression”
and Nanami means “Building Man”.
First, it makes sense because the Kento part
of his name cured the darkness or depression
of the baker lady behind the counter by defeating
the cursed spirit hovering around her, and
he takes out depressing curses on a daily
basis.
On a second thought though, it totally doesn't,
NANAMI LOOKS MORE DEPRESSED THAN ANYONE!
"Building Man” is an interesting one.
I think it probably portrays Nanami’s work-life,
we all know he worked like a dog, building
up his life, until he figured out that being
a salaryman or sorcerer still makes life feel
like shit no matter what..
A major turning point for Itadori occurs when
Kento Nanami is introduced to him by Gojo
while on a mission to investigate the uncanny
deaths of three students at a theater.
Gojo entrusted Nanami with Itadori’s training
on this mission but the two of them had different
core values which made it hard for them to
initially get along.
After hearing his reasoning for joining Jujutsu
Society, Nanami doesn’t approve of teaching
Yuji but can see that he wants to get stronger
so he decided to accompany him either way.
Moving on to the movie theater case, Nanami
teaches Itadori to see the remnants of cursed
energy, and following those said remnants,
the duo comes across cursed spirits.
Throughout the battle, Nanami teaches Yuji
his techniques and showcases his skills in
fighting the cursed spirit’s.
Just when Yuji got his cursed energy all fired
up and was about to finish off the cursed
spirit, Nanami stopped him and instead took
a photo of the curse.
Confused over what he was doing, as typically
curses wont show up in photo’s.
Nanami revealed to Yuji that sadly he wasn't
actually fighting curses, but instead transfigured
humans.
Taking this in shatters Yuji’s morals and
causes him to not feel good about the quickly
evolving situation, but Nanami along with
Shoko on the phone explains that it’s okay
to kill the transfigured humans.
This is pretty much because they’re already
brain dead.
Shoko also explains to Itadori that he wasn't
the one to kill the the transfigured humans
as they had initially died of shock when their
bodies were being modified.
Yuji still cant get over it and reveals that
the death of two transfigured humans he killed
earlier weighed on him heavily.
Seeing Yuji get angry on the behalf of modified
humans, Nanami realized that Yuji can truly
feel empathy for others and take their emotions
on board.
So to snap him out of the downward spiral
he was in, and get Yuji to use those emotions
in combination with his cursed energy, Nanami
explained that it was time to go all-out and
fight the other spirits.
Over in the highschool office now, Nanami
shows a map to Yuji on which he pinned the
locations where unnatural deaths took place,
in an attempt triangulate them and find out
the culprit’s hideout.
Nanami also assigns Itadori to investigate
Junpei to find out more about the theater
case since he was present there.
Itadori gets busy with his own investigation
regarding Junpei and so does Nanami.
While Yuji is off doing his thing with Junpei,
Nanami goes to the sewers and forces Mahito
to leave the dank environment he calls his
place of residence.
Nanami and Mahito’s rivalry begins in the
sewers when Nanami, being punctual, promises
to defeat Mahito quickly as he doesn’t like
to work overtime.
Mahito mocks Nanami by calling him weak and
so the battle begins!
Nanami slashes Mahito with his cursed tool
and manages to break his arm off but it’s
in vain since Mahito, through his Idle Transfiguration
technique, heals his arm and wounds.
Mahito also shows “his collection” of
human stockpiles while explaining how he makes
contact with the human soul and alters their
body shape.
Nanami doesn’t want to waste any time and
has to get off work at 6 PM so he decides
to end the battle as quickly as possible.
Mahito tries his best to tire Nanami out but
you know it’s O-V-E-R when Nanami loosens
his tie and knots it around his hand in preparation
to go overtime mode!!
Yolked up, Nanami explains his 7:3 ratio technique
which creates a weak point at a specific location
and automatically tracks his strike to it.
He also reveals that he can create this line
along more than just their full height or
wingspan and designate it along various body
parts.
For instance, the head, upper arm, forearm,
and so on.
Also on top of that, Nanami’s cursed technique
can affect more than just living creatures.
As the battle continues, it was pretty evident
that there were two ways in which Nanami could
defeat Mahito, one way is to exorcize Mahito
while the other way is to reduce him to smithereens
with a single blow.
Instead though, Nanami creates his 7 ratio
3 line on his opponent’s surroundings and
also cuts Mahito’s leg off.
With Mahito unable to move, Nanami bids farewell
to his opponent as a mountain of bounders
quickly pound the patch face curse into the
floor.
And just like that, my man pushed a currently
Semi-Special Grade cursed spirit to the brink
of death, kinda!
I only say semi right now cause mans still
growing, BUT as we all know, Mahito escapes.
After Mahito escaped, of course, he did the
most despicable thing he could think of and
manipulated Junpei which leads us to the next
moment Nanami appears.
So remember the highschool and Mahito along
with Sukuna laughing their asses off over
Yuji’s mental breakdown, well just after
that Yuji and as Mahito was about to deal
the killing blow, Nanami arrived just in time
to save Yuji.
The grade 1 sorcerer decides to scold the
student for ignoring orders later and asks
for a status update.
Yuji reveals that he was unable to save Junpei
or his mother from the curses.
Nanami notices how Yuji is always thinking
of others before himself and decides to ask
about Yuji's individual status.
Always resilient, and despite being stabbed
several times by Mahito, Yuji insists that
he's fine.
Noticing the salaryman, Mahito expresses his
joy in reuniting with Nanami.
Looking at the curse, Nanami see’s that
his nose is bleeding and comes to the conclusion
that Yuji is able to harm Mahito.
He also quickly realizes that if this is the
case, there must be a reason as to why Mahito
cant currently kill Yuji.
In order to take advantage of this, Nanami
develops a strategy to use his cursed technique
to stifle Mahito's movements while relentlessly
attacking with Yuji, who can eventually land
a killing blow.
The duo prepares for the fight and Nanami
declares that they must exorcise Mahito here
and now.
Mahito prepares himself by creating an eyeball
on his left palm while morphing his other
arm into a bladed shape.
He plans on using the eye to watch Yuji while
focusing on killing Nanami first.
Mahito engages both sorcerers, with Yuji on
his left and Nanami on his right.
Nanami rapidly deflects Mahito's bladed arm
while Yuji goes for a low kick.
Thanks to the eye on Mahito's hand, he's able
to jump above Yuji's kick while sword fighting
with Nanami at the same time.
While in the air, Mahito transforms his entire
body in a sphere of extending spikes.
The sorcerers are able to evade and parry
this to break the spikes apart, making Mahito
immediately regret using this type of attack.
After breaking apart all the spikes, Yuji
and Nanami prepare to deal a massive combined
blow.
However, Mahito is able to evade by transforming
his body into a child-like version of himself
and slips between his opponents.
Having watched this, both Nanami and Yuji
are able to notice that Mahito stores up his
cursed energy just before transforming.
Knowing that one hit from Yuji could kill
him in this smaller form, Mahito changes back
to normal and spews out several small transfigured
humans.
Then using idle transfiguration he creates
several mutated corpses that are ordered to
kill Yuji.
Knowing how mentally incapable Yuji currently
is when it comes to taking a life, Nanami
tries to intercept the transfigured children,
but Mahito who seizes the opening, nearly
takes his head off with his bladed arm.
Seeing it coming, Nanami uses his superior
reflexes and ducks under the blade at the
last second.
With no where to go now, Mahito transforms
his arm into a much larger mutation and pins
Nanami to the wall of a nearby building while
claiming that Yuji won't be able to kill the
mutated humans.
At the same time, Yuji escapes to the roof
and tries to pin down one of the transfigured
humans to avoid fighting.
Hearing the groggy voice of the curse try
and ask for their lives to be ended, their
words horrify Yuji who’s left unable to
do anything.
Mahito plans on having Yuji fight a transfigured
Nanami next and boasts that Yuji is a fool
for not being able to distinguish expectations
from reality.
Nanami who knows that Yuji will eventually
be able to grapple with the idea of fighting
transfigured humans, calmly replies that Mahito
is the fool and Yuji is making that distinction
at this very moment.
Right on cue, Yuji, our boy, jumps down from
the roof and smashes down on Mahito's enlarged
arm, freeing Nanami.
Knowing what was done, Mahito is satisfied
to know that managed to kill the transfigured
humans, but Yuji, who cant yet bring himself
to understand the reasoning for all this bloodshed,
is furious.
Suddenly, Big Nanami appears behind Mahito,
ready to strike with his blunt sword.
In a fraction of a second, the cursed spirit
instantly reacts, confident he can counter
Nanami's cursed technique.
However, Yuji cracks him hard with a strong
right hook, allowing Nanami to follows up
by creating a weak point in Mahito's face
and smashing it with his blunt sword.
The teacher and student lay the absolute fug
out of Mahito until all of a sudden the curse
can feel death approaching.
Using that impending doom to inspire the powers
within the depths of his soul, Mahito conjures
for the very first time, his own Domain Expansion:
The Self-Embodiment of Perfection.
With no escape for the intended target, it
immediately locks Yuji out and traps Nanami
alone inside a void filled with Mahito's soul
transfiguring hands.
Being a grade 1 sorcerer, Nanami is strong
enough to fight against and even beat special
grade curses, because of that and due to the
knowledge he posses on how a domain works,
Nanami immediately realizes how bad of a situation
this currently is.
Happy with himself as per usual, Mahito expresses
his gratitude for the sorcerer helping him
attain this greater level of strength.
Frustrated that Nanami was the only one locked
inside, Yuji rappidly bangs on the outside
of the Domain Expansion with his cursed energy
infused fists.
Inside and understanding the crap he’s in,
Nanami knows he's literally in the palm of
Mahito's hands now.
After looking back on the recent choices he
made in regards to quitting his salaryman
life and re-joining Jujutsu High, Nanami accepts
his fate and tells Mahito to save his gratitude
since he has plenty already.
Taking off his shades, Nanami proudly admits
that he has no regrets.
Suddenly and before Mahito can activate the
sure hit effect of a Domain Expansion, Yuji
breaks into the Domain, by shattering it from
the outside.
This feat btw isnt actually that crazy, a
domains purpose is entrapment, so breaking
on from the outside is something that works
as in theory it should be extremely weak there.
Obviously cause our boy has the demon king
inside of him, this forces Mahito to touch
Yuji's soul, once again angering Sukuna.
Due to the previous meeting, the King of Curses
reminds Mahito that there wouldn't be a second
warning, and slashes his body with two devastatingly
deep cuts.
This in turn severely damages Mahito and destroys
the rest of his domain, dropping him to his
knees, defeated.
Several things instantly run through Yuji's
head leading to the decision that he needs
to act quickly and finish off Mahito.
Feeling knackered, Mahito admits that Domain
Expansion has drained most of his cursed energy
and decides to use what he has left to expand
his body.
Seeing the enlarged balloon of a curse, Yuji
believes that Mahito is weak and unable to
counterattack, so with nothing holding him
back, he filled his fist with a pulse of intent
and strikes Mahito's enlarged body with Divergent
Fist!
However instead of destroying the curse, the
body pops like a balloon and Mahito's real
weakened body escapes back into the sewers.
Seeing it shoot out, Nanami attempts to stop
him by destroying the entrance, but Mahito
manages to scurry away.
That there brings everything inside of the
Mahito Arc with Nanami to an end, he does
briefly make an entrance during the Kyoto
Goodwin Even Arc, but its only to update Gojo
about what happened previously with him and
Yuji at Satozakura high school.
The next time we get to see the big man himself
is during the Shibuya Incident Arc where while
with Megumi and Takuma, the three are informed
of the situation currently going on in Shibuya.
Later, when the citizens get attacked by mutated
humans, Nanami along with Ino and Megumi head
over in order to protect them.
Nanami strategizes and divides the group up
as he wants them to reach Itadori's location.
Once they reach Yuji's location, the mini
Mechamaru explains what had happened to them
against Mahito and what the best course of
action for the upcoming night should be.
Nanami agrees with Kokichi's plans and says
that they will first need to lift the screen
around Shibuya.
He also says that instead of staying with
the younger sorcerers, he will go meet up
with Kiyotaka whilst Megumi, Yuji, and Takuma
deal with
the curtain.
Nanami for the time being puts the professional
sorcerer Takuma in charge and lets them know
that if they bump into Naobito and Kusakabe
they should explain the situation, before
leaving himself.
After journeying through Shibuya, Nanami finds
one of his best friends Kiyotaka lying wounded
on the ground.
Seeing his injuries literally pushes Nanami
to the limit as it reminds him of how he lost
Yu in the past.
Getting furious for his friend, Nanami for
the first time in the series throws away any
thought of holding back and angrily headed
out in search of whoever did this.
NOW HE’S SERIOUSLY PISSED OFF and OML I
love this part of the series, plus Mappa came
through so freaking clutch.
As someone who’s whole reason for even starting
Jujutsu Kaisen, was Nanami, the adaptation
of this section of the manga by Mappa is unreal.
Like I had to re-wind this next part 18,000
times to take in this new kind of feeling.
Like Id never seen my dad on the big screen
before, but on that day, there he stood.
Having come across Nobara in her moment of
need.
Nanami with a conviction that would make the
earth shake, appears at the end of the corridor.
Haruta the freak, like for a villan this dude
is fantastic and I love his messed up demeanor,
but unluckily for him, he was unable to say
anything as he was figuring out if he was
allowed to attack non black suits.
Speaking up, Shigemo tells the newcomer to
read the room and claims to have a hostage
so he shouldnt attack.
To his bewilderment though, Akari crawls up
the escalator to escape from the curse user.
While Shigemo laments about her getting away,
Nanami appears behind him.
Nanami asks where and how many enemies there
are.
Shigemo replies that he doesn't know and turns
around, upward slashing Nanami's shoulder
at the same time.
He tries to follow up with a front kick, but
it's as if he hits a mountain of stone.
Looking up at the sorcerer, Shigemo is confused
since Nanami doesn't budge and he isn't cut
either.
Annoyed, Nanami asks the curse user the same
question again.
Haruta begins to say he doesn't know but Nanami
doesn't even let the dude fully answer before
activating his Ratio Technique.
In an instant, he creates a weak point on
Shigemo's shit eating face and backhands the
child without a second thought.
The impact blows Shigemo tumbling through
the air, destroying anything his way and launching
him across the room into a wall behind Nobara.
Not really knowing much about Nanami, Nobara
is surprised by how ridiculously strong and
overpowered he is in comparison to Shigemo.
Standing up as blood pours from his mouth,
Shigemo believes he'd be dead without his
cursed technique.
Feeling the difference in strength, Shigemo
knows he needs to run but before he can move,
Nanami grabs him by his hair and delivers
a ferocious body blow that slams Shigemo into
the wall, shattering a small part of it from
the impact.
Coughing up even more violently now, Shigemo
communicates with his cursed tool, which levitates
up into the air and attempts to stab Nanami
from behind.
Catching sight of it, Nobara sends one of
her nails into the hand of the cursed tool,
pinning it to the wall.
Shigemo tells her not to interfere but Nanami
grabs him by the throat with his left hand
and begins raising his right hand while filling
full of cursed energy.
Asking the same question once more, Nanami
reveals that he came across several dead assistant
managers on the way here.
He asks the curse user if he was responsible.
Fearful for his life, Shigemo tears up and
apologizes, but it's far too late for that.
Having lifted him up by the throat, Nanami
drops his dumb ass and hits him with one final
blow enhanced by the Ratio Technique, AND
OLORD, MY BOY FLIPS AND SPINS LIKE NO TOMORROW,
NANAMI LEGIT BEYBLADE STYLE LET IT RIP ON
HIS ASS AND SENT HIM THROUGH FREAKING EVERYTHING!
The dude rocketed through a wall outside into
another wall of a building across the street.
As the dust settled, Shigemo was left unconscious
sitting in the crater created by the impact,
with blood profusely pouring from his face.
This here I think for the first time in the
series, makes Nobara realize that Nanami is
on another level, and this is what it means
to be a true grade 1 sorcerer.
I feel like before this moment she was never
there to witness those crazy feats, like Gojo
destroying Hanami in the goodwill arc or anything
to do with the vs Mahito arc.
But here she was witness to what a true Grade
1 sorcerer is made of and what she’ll need
to achieve in the future.
After this, Nanami explains Gojo’s situation
to her and Arata and says he’ll be off to
save him.
Nobara wants to help as well but Nanami explains
that this fight is for grade 1 sorcerers so
she should back down.
I was
truly happy Nanami was given a moment like
this, before the next stuff that happens.
Without it I’d feel like a lot of people
might’ve started to think he an overhyped
teacher, that grade 1 sorcerers weren't all
that impressive and the scaling method in
Jujutsu Kaisen was useless.
With this though, it shows just how large
of a gap there is between each grade of sorcery.
From Nobara at grade 3 to getting dominated
by Shigemo who’s a grade 2 (I think) and
finally the G himself rolling in as a grade
1.
It gives the power system credence and shows
us that sometimes, it doesn't matter what
the technique is, there may just be an overwhelmingly
stronger force that you wont be able to stop.
Either way enough of me rambling absolute
nonsense.
After leaving the girls, Nanami, Naobito,
and Maki come across Dagon, one of the special-grade
cursed spirits.
As the fight starts, Nanami watches Naobito
attacking Dagon and struggling a bit so he
steps in to attack with his own Ration Technique.
He strikes down with his blunt sword on Dagon,
which the curse comfortably blocks with his
forearm.
A second later though and having found the
weak point, Nanami's cursed technique takes
effect, sending Dagon crashing back to the
ground.
Watching the other two sorcerers fighting
Dagon, Nanami dives down on top of the curse
and strike’s him through the frame Naobito
had just stuck him inside.
Instead of getting hit like last time, Dagon
blocks Nanami's sword with a shield of water,
repelling the critical hit and frustrating
Nanami.
With the curse walking forth, a cylinder-shaped
water shield flows in a circle in the air
around Dagon to protect him.
Watching it, Nanami feels like they haven't
done any damage due to the curse's boundless
health.
The sorcerers ready their fighting stances
as Naobito asks what their best course of
action is.
Then they all strike in unison as the old
man reveals that their best way to counter
is to simply overwhelm their adversary before
he can activate any techniques.
The three jujutsu sorcerers all rapidly attack
Dagon's water shield at the same time, threatening
to crush him with pure speed.
As they progress, the sorcerers start slowly
piercing the water shield.
Naobito's fist manages to get through first,
surprising Dagon.
He decides to weave a hand sign detonating
the shield into a massive explosion of water
that forces Nanami and Maki back.
In Naobito’s side of the bout, Dagon attempted
to use another hand sign but Naobito tells
him not to even think about it.
Instantly he pummels Dagon's mid-section as
well as his hands with a flurry of downward
punches, destroying his fingers, making it
impossible to cast hand signs.
However, it turns out to be a simple distraction
as a symbol appears on Dagon's stomach, signaling
the activation of his Domain Expansion.
This traps Naobito in Dagon's coastal domain:
Horizon of the Captivating Skandha.
Ofcourse Nanami’s also trapped inside, along
with Maki who’re both assaulted by piranha-like
shikigami.
The crazy thing about these fish is that they
don't exist until they hit the target due
to the effect of the domain's sure hit effect..
Dagon decides to focus seventy percent of
his power on Naobito and the remaining thirty
percent on Nanami.
He activates Technique Release: Death Swarm,
summoning a literal death swarm of fish shikigami
to his side.
Anticipating the attack, Nanami warns Maki
to attack without hesitation, because if she
doesn't, the shikigami will instantly eat
them alive.
Sadly for our girl, his advice is interrupted
when the shikigami attack Nanami first and
appear to devour his upper body.
Skipping slightly forth and after the goat,
Megumi makes his appearance by using his Domain
Expansion to enter from the outside, Dagon
calls Megumi a fool for entering voluntarily
and motions to attack him.
Having gained the playful cloud, the special
grade weapon with no specific technique from
Megumi’s endless well, Maki stops him by
attacking from behind.
The strike lands, cutting away a good chunk
of Dagon's arm and surprising him with the
force of the impact.
Maki whirls around and uses the momentum of
her spin for a powerful follow-up attack strong
enough to send the special grade skidding
across his own water.
As Dagon recovers from the heavy blows, he
realizes that his guaranteed hit has been
nullified because of Megumi's domain.
To restore Death Swarm Dagon ignores Maki
and focuses on crushing Megumi.
Due to how Megumi is stuck in a domain struggle,
Dagon believes killing Megumi will be simple
and spawns two eel-like shikigami from his
body to attack.
In that moment, the actual rock of a human
makes his re-appearance having survived Death
Swarm for an entire minute and protects Megumi.
Standing next to the first year now, he asks
where Yuji and Ino are and Megumi explains
what happened to each of them.
Grappling with what to do next, Nanami tells
Megumi to focus on his domain while the others
protect him.
Dagon who’s actually baffled with how Nanami
survived Death Swarm from an entire minute
is taken offguard, when Naobito throws a fierce
left hook but Dagon ducks under it.
He's shocked that Naobito aswell managed to
survive Death Swarm's onslaught.
Trying to overwhelm him now, Maki comes up
behind Dagon and ready's her weapon while
simultaneously Dagon blocks a flying knee
from the old man.
Before Playful Cloud hits, Dagon summons two
large shikigami from his body to repel the
sorcerers.
The shikigami initially pushes Naobito across
the sand but the grade 1 sorcerer traps it
inside a frame and crushes it with a powerful
stomp.
Behind Naobito, more shikigami head toward
Megumi but Nanami stops them with his Ratio
Technique, slashing them apart with ease.
He believes that they might win if they can
keep up this momentum, but as blood begins
to drip from Megumi’s nose, its evident
he’s reaching his limit.
Surprising Nanami, Megumi reveals that he's
not actually in the midst of a domain battle.
He's trying to open a hole in the barrier
so they can escape rather than enforcing his
own expansion.
In his eyes, Dagon likely can't use domain
expansion again so if the sorcerers can escape,
then they can win.
Due to how he entered, Megumi is sure the
barrier's edge is right below.
Nanami tells him that he better not be planning
to stay behind himself, to which Megumi affirms
that he doesn't plan on throwing his life
away.
Not just yet anyway haha.
Watch this if you wanna know what I mean.
(Mahoraga video Sukuna vs Mahoraga)
Nanami calls out to his allies, asking Maki
and Naobito to assemble.
He does so in a roundabout way, but the Zenin
Team trusts Nanami and heads toward Megumi.
Confused, Dagon wonders why they would get
in a group and make it easier for him to attack.
It takes a moment, but he quickly realizes
Megumi's plan and panics, rushing to follow
them a step too late.
Nanami sees that Dagon's figured it out but
believes it's too late for him to stop them
now.
On cue, Megumi opens the hole and everyone
readies themselves to leave the domain, but
suddenly an unsuspecting intruder enters through
it.
The recently resurrected Toji Fushiguro uses
the opportunity to climb through the hole
into the domain, forcing everyone there to
bear witness to the flesh of the one who is
free and all his overwhelming intensity.
So im skipping over everything that happens
with Toji because well Nanami doesn't really
have anything to do with what's about to happen.
Like im pretty sure he might only asks who’s
side he’s on, but thats about in from here
until the end of the Toji vs Dagon beatdown.
After merking the Fish, Toji, the puppet of
carnage, drags Megumi off to deal with his
son for the first time in his life.
Instantly after, Jogo who’s shown up on
the block launches a surprise attack on the
already injured three remaining sorcerers.
In that moment, Jogo also says his final farewells
to Dagon and just like that blitzes Nanami,
igniting the upper half of his body..
This sadly is where the beginning of the end
for Nanami’s story started…
After this Jogo and Sukuna went head-to-head
and as Yuji was finally given control of his
body after the fight, he had an emotional
breakdown after seeing the destruction he
had caused.
Probably somewhere nearby below Yuji, Nanami
wakes up in a daze.
His upper body is completely decimated with
the left half of it being burned to a crisp
by Jogo’s previous attack.
Even the entire left side of his face is but
burnt flesh and bone.
He keeps on walking, pushing forth when suddenly
a swarm of transfigured humans meet him.
As he does his last stand, slicing and hacking
into every transfigured human that comes towards
him, he daydreams about Malaysia and the ideal
life he wants to live there.
He starts to look for Megumi and says that
he’s “just tired” while still fighting
like it is second nature to him.
That was until the worst thing that could
happen, came into fruition....
Mahito appears in front of him, with his hand
placed on his chest.
The cursed spirit tries to strike up a conversation
with him but Nanami is already at his wits
limit.
He hallucinates and talks to his late partner,
Yu Haibara.
He contemplates why he comes back to being
a sorcerer and as he finishes his question,
Yu Haibara points at something to his right.
In that moment, Nanami looked over and saw
Yuji running into his room.
Ahh this moment always cuts deep, but as you
could imagine, this was the perfect situation
for Mahito.
Still fading between life and death, Nanami
says his to best friend, Yu, that he doesn’t
want to end up cursing Yuji for his fate.
With that as his final thoughts, Nanami smiles
sincerely at Yuji, the student who meant so
much to him, and says his final words “You’ve
got it from here”.
As he finishes that statement, Mahito uses
his cursed technique and destroys Nanami’s
entire upper body, giving Yuji one of the
most traumatic scenes he would ever see.
After Nanami’s death, Itadori gets enraged
and is determined to take revenge for his
fallen mentor.
Mahito, on the other hand, sends a small transfigured
human at Itadori and transforms it into one
that can produce spikes from its head!
Preoccupied by the feeling of rage and revenge,
Itadori gets ready to fight!
Mahito not only killed Itadori’s mentor
but also his close friend, Junpei.
So, keeping the people close to his heart
and mind, Yuji becomes determined to finish
off Mahito.
Indeed Kento Nanami’s death left a deep
impact on everyone especially Itadori since
Nanami died right in front of his eyes.
At first, he couldn’t believe that Nanami
had died, just like most of us.
But In the end, it resulted in some hardcore
character development for our boy, since he
felt emotions like “rage” and “hatred”
towards a specific being for the first time
in his life.
Yuji lost someone he looked up to, someone
who might have possibly replaced the gap left
by his grandpa.
So, it left a scar on his heart.
From not wanting to kill mutated humans to
wanting to DESTROY all his enemies, Itadori
changed a lot and Nanami’s death was a catalyst
of what was to come.
Thank you if you have made it to the end of
the video, if you want me to cover a few more
of Jujutsu Kaisens characters lives in full,
then make sure to let me know who down below.
Preferably id do the ones who have passed
on, as that gives me a solid beginning and
end and I wont have to come back and redo
the characters.
Subscribe if you are new around here and want
to watch a bunch of similar anime and manga
content, plus leave a like as it really helps
out with pushing my content to a bunch of
new amazing people.
But for now its been your professional degenerate
Diavolo and ill see you all in a bit, bye!